[Music]
Patricia Cornwell is a number one New
York Times best-selling novelist her
latest effort portrait of a killer turns
to the real-life slayings of Jack the
Ripper which terrorized 1880s London
recently she addressed the Virginia
Institute of Forensic Science where she
serves as a chairman of the board it's
about an hour in 20 minutes
thank you for coming in this dark night
to participate in our benefit tonight I
just want to say very briefly that it's
been a very long time since Patricia
Cornwell and I went to court and ended
up in North Carolina because we headed
the wrong way and interstate 85
this day at time she's managed to find
her way across the ocean several times
to work on Jack the Ripper and it's a
great pleasure for me to introduce her
to you tonight and you may have a bonus
because she has some special information
for you so good evening and welcome
Patsy
[Applause]
and I go to make a new broader community
now I have so many mics on can you hear
me say that mic and that might does that
mean why do I need two mics anyways long
everybody can hear me right good good
good
you know this is really special this is
this is actually my last stop or as your
police would say end of tour it's the
last stop on my book tour which is
included places here in the United
States and London where I topped the
charts for being their favorite person
because I didn't realize that Jack the
Ripper was in fact a national treasure
and not a serial killer
till I spent the week of being the one
on trial and it was a very bizarre
experience which I'll maybe share a
little bit more about that at first if
there's any British people in the room I
highly suggest that if you ask a
question disguise your voice because I'm
a little sensitive right now thank you
for being here the best part of this is
what it's all about because this
forensic Institute the Virginia
Institute of forensic science and
medicine you're right it's all about
getting bad people off the road get
getting them off the street sooner
because we need more scientists to do
that and the way this all began and then
I'm going to get into Jack the Ripper
because you guess what what better
people to kick butt and bring that guy
to justice than these folks right here
and I mean amazing 114 year-old case I
didn't solve it the scientist did and
I'm going to tell you more about that
but right here in Virginia which
includes the Bodie laboratories I will
say a few people in Great Britain who
are wonderful who did help but this is
an amazing accomplishment and it tells
you one thing that is never ever too
late for justice and justice is not
about the dead justice is about us
because it causes us to a reach to a
higher level of our own being and say
you know what life matters goodness
matters fairness matters and evil should
be stamped out as you'd be put behind
or in some cases I leave it up to you or
else maybe it should be put whether I'm
not going to get into controversial
subjects although we do know that
Virginia has lots of needles so but you
know this institute is about justice and
I am you know and I begged all of you is
you go out in your communities to please
ask people to support the Virginia
Institute it is not funded by state
money at this point it is funded by all
of us who are interested in it and
although I'm not going to go into a
sermon about it you need to understand
that there is such a critical shortage
of forensic scientists in this country I
think it's more than 11-thousand that we
would need to prep to be perhaps up to
par I know where's dr. dr. Ferrara is
that about right he would say so even he
would embarrass me in public but it's
severe severe shortage so what does that
mean that means that if you have a
rape-murder that if you don't have a
suspect in particular that that evidence
is going to languish on a shelf in some
places not as much in Virginia anymore
because we lead the pack in
enlightenment we do indeed it could
languish on a shelf for a year while
this guy runs around and kills somebody
else rapes somebody else who knows how
many times so speaking of the TV shows
it doesn't happen like that I mean not
everybody has this great space age and
for the bodhi people I honestly didn't
know that you could do mitochondrial DNA
in one hour I am just you know I wish
you'd told me that because I've been
waiting three friggin months for my
result the only danger of these programs
and I think it's great that they get
people interested but the danger is that
they don't watch them except maybe once
but I know about them because I have to
admit I like watching biography and and
I don't watch TV much at all but anyway
the danger is people get the false
notion that every laboratory in medical
examiner's office and all of Christendom
is magnificently equipped
and has their own team of forensic techs
you might say that that are running
around the crime scenes well you know
something that's just not it I'll tell
you where I was recently I was in Baton
Rouge Louisiana where there's a terrible
you know horrendous serial killings
going on and in that case they do not
have a DNA database in Louisiana they
have three victims now that are
connected to the same killer by DNA but
no DNA database I went to the mortgage
in a trailer the guy who quit the sink
by buying one salvaged from a restaurant
he bought a morgue refrigerator from a
funeral home that only holds three
bodies he's done a remarkable job I kid
you not I don't make fun of him but
there are places in this country where
the conditions and the needs are just
would make you cry so we need to be
training as many people here as we can
to send out the troops because it is
about all of us and it is about justice
and there's never too late for justice
and God forbid that someone should be
out on the street one day longer and
somebody dies the way Jack the Ripper
this case happened I had first of all
absolutely no interest in the world in
Jack the Ripper I think we all know
there are plenty cases that go on now
that take a lot of our attention and so
a hundred and fourteen year old case
never entered my mind until I happened
to have be visiting Scotland Yard a year
ago this past May and got connected with
one of the top people at the yard who
happens to know a good deal about the
Jack the Ripper case what little is
really known or has been known about it
and I simply got into an investigative
discussion not a what you call Ripper
expert or a Ripper ology or whatever
type discussion because I don't know
anything about the theories or didn't
and don't know much about them even now
but what struck me about this
conversation which I look better the
darker dis just so you know
I mean the makeup artist was great but
so you had this okay what are you doing
to me anyway distracting me
what struck me about this case first of
all was when I said who are the suspects
after I was told a little bit about the
crimes there were no suspects that were
linked to these murders by any evidence
whatsoever whether it was three
individuals that the police named mainly
in the early 1900's one was a poor
barrister who committed suicide and that
seemed a convenient way to decide that
he was Jack the Ripper and his mind
snapped and he put rocks in his pockets
and jumped into the Thames but I will
tell you that his mother had just been
committed to an asylum that summer after
trying to commit suicide and a sister
later committed suicide and I have my
new Drouet for those of you who know
that name he did not go around killing
these women I don't know how much you
know and there are several others that
have been named and then quite a few
that have been a martial force in recent
decades because theorizing about this
crime is of great interest to many many
many people because it has remained
perhaps the the largest mysterious or
most notorious unsolved crime probably
in history and if you don't if you're
not very familiar with it as it has been
known what is known most about it is is
that there were five victims that's not
true but this is what has been stated
five victims in the modus operandi
mainly was that this Jack the Ripper
character would sort of appear in the
slums you kind of see him as the man of
the mist truth is people really didn't
see him but what he would do to these
unfortunates as they were called or
prostitutes is he would cut their
throats and then his violence progressed
he would slit them open and then the
bowels were being thrown on the pavement
and organs were being taken and finally
on November 9th 1888 the murder of Mary
Kelly and you can see the picture in my
book and I didn't put it in there to be
gratuitously gross I think it is very
important that you see the degree of
horrendous violence that this man
perpetrated upon his victims he is not a
legend he is not something that doesn't
exist he is not a puzzle to be solved he
is not a mystery weekend he is not a
Ripper walk he is not a feature madame
tussauds he is a vicious serial killer
and god only knows how many people he
killed before he died at the age of 81
in 1942 which is probably which shocked
me when I first thought about it because
there are plenty of people you know who
are still alive who were who are alive
and you know have spent some of the same
years on this planet that Jack the
Ripper or Walter Sickert did these were
horrendous crimes Mary Kelly and I
noticed there are a lot of experts in
this room tonight and many people I
noticed bill bill hag Myer I see you
back there who's one of the top
profilers psychological profilers you're
ever find and he knows a lot about this
sort of thing so I'm not going to get
into his turf at all but you have a
tremendous amount of rage for a man to
take a prostitute I'm sure perhaps lured
her into the little slovenly place she
was living in this was a stalker you see
Mary Kelly she was very pretty she was
about 25 she was sliding down the
pecking order of prostitutes in London
your West End was the nicer sort of call
girls you might say and then as they
became more and more jaded they ended up
in the East End or as Jack London the
writer called it the abyss which is the
poverty and I described this in my book
the poverty the violence the inhumanity
the way children and women and the way
the sweatshops it is disgusting the
slaughterhouses were literally blood and
entrails were in the streets the mud and
when you hear about London Fog well
guess what when I started doing this
research and I decided you know I have
to do my typical thing
and I can't make any assumptions and I
wanted to get all original material
not anything derivative but go right
back to the early sources of everything
including the original newspapers and
what have you what was the first thing I
had to ask what what is London Fog
besides a raincoat what is it and so I
began to get some some books in the 19th
century books on this whole thing and as
you probably have guessed London Fog was
really terrible smog everybody was using
coal fires and the smog was so bad that
it was said that you could smell London
long before you could see it when you
were journeying there and many many
people died of respiratory diseases and
sometimes the fog was so yellow and
acrid from the sulfuric smoke that came
out of this coal that people would have
to walk around with handkerchiefs over
their faces so in addition to misty
conditions rain and I give you the
weather for every single day that these
murders occurred right down to how many
hours the Sun shone because I had access
to that the times which I consider the
newspaper of record in London and you'll
find this fascinating because it ain't
true today but back then the newspaper
was such high quality that when a book
dealer was able to find the original
times the paper was so good they ironed
it and then they bound it in leather
books can you listen would you like to
iron USA today and see what happens so
no disparagement of what's in it but I
don't think it would hold up very well
in one of my leather notebooks so but
but these newspapers they they was it
was it was fabulous I mean they tell you
what temperature it was at two o'clock
in the morning so you can imagine a Mary
Kelly or Mary Ann Nichols or Elizabeth
stride or any Chapman or Catherine
Eddowes some of the victims attributed
to the Ripper you can imagine them going
out into this filthy smog in the cold
raw weather sometimes it was raining and
because they had no place to live except
for Mary Kelly who was to be evicted
next morning because she
one pound nine shillings behind in the
rent they would go out and they'd wear
everything they own because they were
basically street people and then they
would try to sell their bodies and earn
enough pennies to buy a bed for the
night in a lodging house these were
terrible places these were terrible
places as well
you know these flea infested crowded
lodging houses were for pennies for a
bed and then they'd go out usually
they'd get up very late generally go to
the pub have a few eye-opening shots of
something because they were basically
all alcoholics and you can see how one
would feed on the other the more you
drank the less you had to really process
what you were doing to earn the money
and so the more you drink the more you
had to do the prostitution and the more
you did the prostitution the more you
drank and Jack the Ripper was a freaking
coward because to go after these women
was shooting fish in a barrel and for
all his savagery he never picked on
anybody his own size he killed these
poor women whether there were
prostitutes or later on dancehall
women we don't know who all he killed
but he didn't kill anybody who was a
match for him
and I even believe he poor as possible
he killed at least several children and
he admitted to that he predicted he
would in his letters and there were
hundreds of letters that he wrote to the
police and the press and they have
largely been dismissed as hoaxes over
the years but this is where forensic
science comes to play because at the end
of the day when we started when I
started thinking about suspects and my
circuit board sort of lit up because I
thought from one hundred fourteen year
old case I said to John Greaves a
Scotland Yard person has anybody ever
applied modern forensic science modern
forensic medicine modern police
investigative techniques to this crime
these crimes and he said no well you
know why the yard wouldn't because they
have other things to do Jack the Ripper
clearly is not out there anymore so they
can't even though there's no statute of
limitation on
homicide you don't go running around
trying to catch people who killed people
a hundred or thousand years ago so I
said well you know it might just be
interesting because okay what evidence
is left to test the only evidence we
have that int that we know of because in
those days it really wasn't forensic
science using policing so if you could
imagine this when they find a body on
the street and she's been disemboweled
and her kid one of her kidneys is gone
and her uterus is taken they they would
take her to the mortuary they
immediately would wash down the street
they had no photography that could be
taken at night and they would take her
to a workhouse mortuary which was
nothing more than what you might call it
you know just a dead house a horrible
little shed and inmates could take care
of the body now if you ever seen dumber
and dumber I'm going to tell you about
these two in Hatfield and this other guy
can't remember his name would you wait
to read about these two guys excuse me
in this one mortuary where they handled
two of the victims it's almost comical
accepted so tragic because they didn't
didn't have a clue and they were so
addled during the inquest that I have no
idea whatever really happened to those
four women when these guys were sort of
cleaning them up to make them nice and
tidy for the doctor and I would I don't
think I'd want to benefit so they would
just throw the clothes away the only
purpose of clothing was to identify a
victim B so there was no such thing as
trace evidence and looking for fibers
and looking for all the amazing things
that you look for now there was no DNA
they couldn't tell animal from human
blood
now hospitals good they're
microscopically they could but that
wasn't used in police work so there were
no crime scenes in a sense and a lot of
these were outside so where's the
evidence Walter Sickert
Jack the Ripper made one very big
mistake and this is what has done him in
he was an obsessive letter writer and he
was incredibly arrogant he thought
everybody in the world was stupider than
him well he wasn't stupid but you know
what I'm
he thought everybody was a fool but him
he was brilliant he spoke at least five
or six languages he was an artist in the
1800s he wasn't the apprentice and
apprentice to James McNeill Whistler he
was a student of Degas he was married to
the daughter of one of the most
prominent politicians in England who
conveniently was dead by the time
Sickert met Allen the daughter because
Richard Cobden the politician would have
seemed through this man in a minute and
would never have wanted him to marry any
of his daughters because secret what had
a psychopathic personality disorder and
although he could be charming and
charismatic anybody I can't imagine
anybody spending much time who had any
sort of acumen or intuition who wouldn't
realize there was nobody home no
conscience all about oneself started out
as an actor an egomaniac and he hated
women and he was very handsome not at
all what the police were looking for
back then and he made a big mistake
he decided his big haha was he would
write as he's committing these atrocious
crimes and you'll see in my book the
circumstantial evidence that shows you
how easy it was for him to do this
because he had secret Studios he could
go many places and nobody knew where he
was it was this habit to disappear days
even weeks at a time without people
knowing where he was he loved to roam
the slums he went to the music halls
which were sexually very provocative in
some cases almost pedophilia because
they had little girls dressed in very
sexual ways and they were almost
pornographic some of them with these
scantily dressed women that were not
typical for the Victorian era so he was
in he would roam Whitechapel the areas
where these crimes he'd sometimes stay
out there all night so and sorry I'm
getting over the same cold everybody
else's but there's a lot of
circumstantial evidence but mmm the
letters he started writing these letters
September 17th 1888 is the first one
that we know of and in it
he named himself Jack the Ripper this
wasn't done by the press Walter Sickert
gave himself that name you know dr.
Jekyll and mr. Hyde was you know full
houses every night at the Lyceum theater
during this time well
Sicard came up with a stage name for
himself that would be remembered long
after that play it he it's you know he
orchestrated the greatest show on earth
with these letters that ended up in the
newspapers that made this name infamous
everybody knows it even now but he left
evidence on these letters there are to
date 211 Jack the Ripper letters still
existed and are preserved at the public
record office in London these are
letters that were sent to the
Metropolitan Police there are 300
letters that are the corporation of
London records although I think that the
vast majority of those truly are from
citizens who were simply concerned and
frightened about these cases because
they did leave legitimate names and
addresses although they're definitely
some that that sicker Jack the Ripper
wrote but so this is what we started on
the first obvious thing to do is well
what about DNA so the team as I call it
you know doctor for dr. Ferrara
you know people from the Institute and
for anybody doesn't think this place
knows what it's doing let me tell you
these people came over to London and
they we got permission from the British
government first time ever in history
that the British government allowed
people to come into their laboratory and
because of their conservation laboratory
and analyze the Jack the Ripper original
letters this was a really big deal and I
don't and because of the credentials of
the people here with this Institute
that's how we got the permission I'd
like to tell you it's because of me but
that just isn't so it's one thing to be
number one on a best-seller list over
there it's another thing that don't turn
up with a q-tip and knock on a door so
I gotta tell you one funny story about
that we went in and they're doing all
the swabbing you know using the sterile
water
Lisa Scheer Meyer Paul and they're
they're peeling back these stamps in the
flaps these awful mean nasty ugly
confessional violent letters I'm going
to read you a couple of minutes and the
guy who is basically the in charge of
conservation and he's a good guy but he
didn't know doodle squat about DNA so
when they're peeling these things back
and then he sees a and and they're
peeling them back and swabbing and
they're trying to sort of land back down
he's going and he's blowing on
everything and we're Lisa sitting there
like this and and I was thinking you
know Mario you are going to be Jack the
Ripper if you don't stop this and he's
blowing away trying to dry everything
and so finally Paul Paul says to Mario
he says you know we are going to have to
get a buccal swab and his eyes got as
big as he chandeliers because what does
buccal sound like doesn't sound like
your mouth to me and I said Paul give
him a cup in one glove I dare you tell
him to go in the men's room and come
back so he got the inside and I just
tell him all it is it's just one cheek
right well Paul what was too
professional to do that so Mario had to
be slob
been told not to blow on things ever
again so they did a number of the DNA
tests not on all the letters but on some
because they'd been laminated which was
our heartbreak we can we come in we're
so excited we find out all these letters
they take in plastic membranes membranes
and ironed them you know it's like you
do when you put something on a t-shirt
and cheese and they'd put these
membranes on these letters and we all
know that well heat when it gets high
enough is not a real good thing for DNA
and also you can't swab through these
things and I'll never forget I went back
to the hotel that night and I just sat
on the edge of the bed staring into
empty space
and I felt like the whole world had come
to an end because it was like this was
such a great chance the oldest DNA ever
examined in a criminal case and they had
to put they had to conserve these damn
things shame on them but then believe it
or not though they actually allowed the
Institute people to they remove the
membranes from move these to peel these
things off they use I don't know heat
water I don't know what you did Paul of
course methanol that was the next thing
I was going to say so they peeled those
those up you know you ever notice when
you call on the real people they don't
say anything that makes sense you know
it's if it's they come out with these
words this is why I don't do public
readings because I cannot pronounce half
of what I've written because I get it
from people like that I don't know what
that what they're talking about so
anyway they used the methanol and took
these things off and then they did the
swabbing we also swab six letters
because he has quite an archive and see
our hope was well our first hope was we
were going to get DNA you know like one
out of you know sixty billion people
five times the population of the world
or whatever that could have left the
profile on the Ripper letters and on the
secret letters long story short that
didn't happen we could not get any
nuclear DNA but thanks to the bodhi
people when these swabs were recent were
submitted to their laboratories we did
get mitochondrial DNA which is one
particularly for you in law enforcement
to remember how very important this
lesser-known type of DNA is because it
is so sturdy and there's about I think
thousand times more of it in cells he's
nodding I have to look over there he's
kind of my cue guy and I mean it's you
know and so we got mitochondrial where
you couldn't get the nuclear and a
sequence that you know the genetic
markers in this sequence are not
anywhere near as significant but you
could safely say that only like one
percent of the
population could have left a sequence
that was found on several ripper samples
and several secret samples I think one
percents not so bad but today in court
you know well you have 5.6 million
people in London back then that's 50,000
600 although I will tell you that
according to a guy whose claim to fame
is he has a Ripper website he did
announce the people magazine that that
left hundreds of thousands of people and
so I've you know I said gee his math is
worse than mine and why is it if you
have a Ripper website that makes you an
expert suddenly on mitochondrial DNA but
that's some of what I've been dealing
with out there but I will tell you for
those who don't know this case does not
rest
just on the mitochondrial DNA and we
still have 50 samples that Bodhi is
testing but the other secret wouldn't
have known about DNA he did know about
watermarks he did know about artistic
mediums and he used an abundance of
these on the letters I don't know why
the police never noticed at least 10% of
the Ripper letters have watermarks and I
think you know what that is if you hold
up a piece of stationery and you see a
crest or a name written you can see it
in the light that's a watermark and it's
the name of the manufacturer or your own
personal watermark a very common when
you see here's cranes just to give you
an example so just to give you a few
little things we found because I'm not
going to you can ask me questions and we
can get into more of this but I have
some other things I want to tell you
anyway just a few bits of evidence along
with the DNA we found six it's at least
six different watermarks in Ripper
letters that are also in Walter Sickert
stationery he used four letters at were
around this time well that is exactly
that is one fifth of the Ripper letters
that have watermarks now you can say
that's a coincidence because well there
might have been a lot of paper out there
with that watermark with this watermark
or the other watermark may be a
coincidence okay so the mitochondrial 1%
whatever
coincidence
six different water what marks Oh maybe
a coincidence then we get to the
coincidence of water-based paints
lithography crayons China graph crayons
sketching pen nibs sketches that show
great technical skill these are all on
Ripper letters paintbrush strokes now
what kind of Looney tune East End er and
they were always polish you'd always
polish Russian and always Jewish by the
way and they you know and back then they
believed in physiography which means you
had a brow about that big and little
teeny eyes and really big jaw you sort
of look like you know the Neanderthal
that was the sort of person who
committed these crimes and by the way if
you were a pedophile
you were very that you had a bit of a
lilting or wispy and were blonde and
women who were criminals were incredibly
ugly always according to physiography
back in those days so so secret would
actually make fun of this by drawing
pictures like that you know here's a
photograph of me and you draw this
Neanderthal guy you can see a picture of
it in my book and if you look very
carefully this is extremely
sophisticated drawing it's not a very
pretty picture but extraordinarily
sophisticated so we have that we have
the brushstrokes my favorite though is
for those of you who have any
familiarity with the Jack the Ripper
letters some of its always been said the
number of them seem to be smeared with
blood now there very well may be blood
on some of these letters I know Lisa got
an inconclusive
could be maybe not you know degrading
from the heat and who knows what else is
we really probably will never know if
human blood is on some of those letters
but one of the most fascinating things
that turned up is on this one they had
all this goopy brown stuff on it that's
supposed to be blood according to the
Ripper Peter Bauer who's one of the
probably the top forensic paper
scientist in the world who began working
on this case as well did a swab of this
and he looked at it microscopically
because he had a suspicion about it what
he thought it was
is something called itching ground an
etching ground is just a sort of waxy
substance that if you were doing an
etching you would cover a copper plate
with it and then you take a sharp sharp
object and you would draw your sketch
through it and then you'd use acid and
that would bite this you know bite into
the plate except for where the waxy
stuff is roll it with ink put the paper
on and you have an etching now tell you
was something very and Walter Sickert
was doing etchings at this time in his
life that is something he learned from
Whistler so he Peter Bower does this
microscopic evaluation of this goopy
stuff and it turns out that it is
etching ground it's white wax resin and
oil now you can only get that in studios
the artist mixed it themselves you don't
buy it over the counter now you want to
call that a coincidence well one thing
we're beginning to ascertain is an
artist wrote a lot of these letters we
have the DNA that hints that Walter
Sickert may have written at least some
of these letters but I want to tell you
about the most recent find and I brought
this with me because this has been
really frustrating but wonderful is
since I finished the book evidence keeps
coming in there's going to be one hell
of a paperback because I got a file it's
already like two feet thick because you
know all its I keep finding out things
evidence is tested now the other letters
show up and this is rather remarkable
and I want it I want to give you to show
you what forensic science can do in a
case so impossible Jack the Ripper's
said in a letter you haven't caught me
and you never will this guy named one of
the Ripper people someone who's a you
know spent a lot of time studying it
I've heard the story that when we all
die and go to heaven and want to know
who and find out who Jack the Ripper is
it will be someone we never had heard of
before well first of all I don't think
Jack the Ripper is going to be in heaven
so you can dismiss that remark but
secondly we I do believe we know who
Jack the Ripper is in all through
science so here we go just a month or so
ago I happened to be in Southern
California
and this art historian who used to think
that the idea of secret being Jack the
Ripper was ridiculous quote laughable
she put in a book a woman named dr. Anna
Robbins I was talking to her on the
phone and she said you know I just
discovered there's some more secret
letters there at the Getty Research
Institute and I said you're kidding me I
mean I'm right there I'm just right
outside of Los Angeles and I thought oh
no I don't want to go look at any more
of his letters the book is turned in I'm
at a Billie Jean King fundraiser I get
to play in a pro-am on the am part big
time and and I wasn't in a if I have to
give up the tennis if I'm going to go
and of course the wiser voice in me said
you have to do this so I went to the
Getty Research Institute found some
secret letters that date back to about
the period of the Ripper now let me let
me say we have had a hard time finding
secret letters that go back to that
period I think he was very busy writing
other letters which is why he wasn't
writing a lot of other people so but
these are two letters that that written
were written on his mother's stationery
to an art dealer nothing of great
consequence - I have the photographs of
him here but nothing really interesting
to read to you except that the paper had
a watermark has a watermark on it called
gurney I've relayed isn't that kind of a
weird coincidence
gurney where's Marcella but I sort of
think you know is kind of like the
deadly blow for you big guy because this
was a really this is a bad piece of
evidence and he sure as heck would go to
court on it the gurney ivory laid paper
I did my little thing as I sketched it
and I wrote the measurements and drew
the watermark because they wouldn't let
me take pictures sent it to Peter Peter
calls me and he says you know I don't
want to I don't want to be too
optimistic here but first of all this
gurney I relayed is a watermark that is
in two other Ripper letters that I know
of well this was a new one I didn't know
about this
he said but don't get too excited I
think it's from the same paper badge now
this is a really big deal because if for
example your John Doe friendly face
Canaries store and you order a gurney
ivory laid paper to make stationery and
you're getting low on it so you contact
the manufacturer the manufacturer
contacts the paper mill or whatever
and anyway you going to get a run of
this a batch of paper made well gurney
ivory laid was a small paper maker
manufacturer and in fact most of the
paper they made was used for newsprint
and brown wrapping paper and it was
unusual for them to make stationery now
the way this worked back then without
getting too complicated is if you had a
certain watermark you wanted used on
paper whoever made this for you such as
the gurney I relayed company whatever it
was called and I have that in his ten
page report they put on this thing
called a dandy roll and it was a wire
roll that had your watermark crafted out
of wire on it and when the paper would
come through this machine when it would
hit that dandy roll the watermark would
be impressed in the paper which gives it
that translucent appearance when you
hold it up to a light or in our case put
it on a light box but we're so
fascinating about paper manufacturing is
whenever you put that dandy roll on and
whenever you made a batch no two batches
are alike they're like fingerprints
because imperfections are put into that
vet paper such as you're just variations
you're going to find the fiber count is
different the surface finish may be
different the watermark might be
slightly off-center it might be slightly
distorted there could be a number of
things that that a paper expert like
Peter would notice but what's most and
so he narrowed it down to this well and
he swears by this he's an expert witness
in court so this is not my information
according to his calculations they're
probably this company would have made
about a quarter of a ton in a run of
paper that would have been six thousand
sheets of paper that had the watermark
because as you can imagine when you cut
the paper not every piece has a
watermark on it
then I was excited enough about that me
my god four pieces of paper out of six
thousand that you that would ever have
these imperfections on them but then it
got better because you he went and met
with some other paper experts and in the
Victorian era if you went to buy
stationery it was sold by the choir qu
ir e which is 24 sheets and in the KN in
most cases it was folded paper you had
the address on the front and you could
tear it down the middle if you wanted to
cut it in half or whatever but that and
it was a certain in this case a certain
size so when they wanted to you know
produce a choir of paper they would use
what they called the guillotine and they
would cut those 24 sheets now thankfully
for human error these settings for the
guillotine were almost always not
precise because someone did it by hand
and is supposed to be exactly 90 degrees
and in this case of course it was not 90
degrees and the number of degrees off in
the cutting of these of the paper these
two secret letters these two Ripper
letters are identical meaning they're
from the same 24 sheets of paper and
that's rather interesting too because
the two Ripper letters are on his
mother's stationery so it kind of makes
me wonder if something wasn't going well
at home so now we just to pursue this
tad bit farther than I don't want to let
you guys ask questions because you know
I don't want to go on for 500 pages
because you can read all this stuff
later but that's not in the book because
this just happened so you're not you
know it's there's plenty in the book I
think to make you not like Walter
Sickert very much but this is the latest
and yes this amazing stuff so I
presented this in London so now the new
argument this is a good argument is okay
well just because Walter Sickert wrote
at least some of the Jack the Ripper
letters that doesn't mean he killed
anybody a good defense attorney would
say that and Walter Sickert would
probably playing golf and having road
rage in Florida right
now so if you had a jury stupid enough
to follow that line of thinking but
what's important is that these letters
are confessional and as my Scotland Yard
friend said that is really what the
argument is about is if you can say
because we cannot connect Walter Sickert
really without irrefutably to a crime
scene nobody means how could we do that
114 years later but we can irrefutably
connect him to at least a few of these
letters and I'm willing to tell you that
I think he wrote probably about 90% of
them and some at some point I hope you
get an opportunity to look at these
letters because you will find you know
with the art mediums the watermarks the
the very forced disguised handwriting
that threw people off at least five six
different types of handwriting but let
me just tell you one detail about sicker
when you when you made these when you
did these etchings if you can imagine
when you when you put the paper over the
inked plate and you turn it over or your
image is reversed so if you vexed your
name on it your name is backwards this
guy was so skilled in writing that he
could write his name in cursive
backwards and when it was on the etching
I mean you really you could almost not
tell that he did not written it the
regular way and he brags in a ripper
letter I can write in five different
hands I think he might have been
somewhat ambidextrous I have some things
in there about the handwriting I won't
go into detail right now but these
Ripper letters are very confessional and
a psychologist that I just recently
talked to who is at Williams College I
was talking he's an expert in
confessional confessions whether they're
true or or somebody just confessing and
one thing he said was you one of the
ways that you can tell when someone's
confessing to something he really didn't
do like let's say secret was just a
crank is that every time the details of
the
case change in the newspaper the person
tends to change his story to follow what
the latest evidence is well Jack the
Ripper didn't do that what he did was is
the son when the police were on the
wrong track he made fun of them I just
want to read you two letters two two
Ripper letters because I suspect you you
don't sit around reading these all the
time you might be curious this is just a
little one that was written on October 8
1888 okay somebody put something in it
sit Whitechapel this excuse me dear boss
mmm dear boss by the way referred to
Charles Warren or any top police
official he just called him boss
Charles Warren was a commissioner of the
Metropolitan Police then dear boss
although you have not yet succeeded in
catching me I presume you live and open
I'm not sure what that means I have not
yet settled my account with [ __ ] and
mean to do the Dozen I originally stated
yours with love Jack the Ripper well he
is predicting he's going to kill some
more this one is really interesting and
again I got to tell you I don't know if
you can see that some of this stuff this
is really hard to read and particularly
this this is probably red ink but some
of them are written with red lithography
crayons I just smear all over the place
this one's yet a different handwriting
but just just listen to this and tell me
if this sounds like a confessional
letter from somebody who didn't do
anything and is maybe changing his story
all the time when the press does excuse
me dear boss you are the biggest fool in
London I am in Leicester now for holiday
what advance what a dance I am leading
all all the fools about London why I am
passing them by dozens against Scotland
Yard way and don't I laugh and say
damned fools you work them too hard poor
fellows but excuse me
it's so hard to read you work them so
hard for fellows but but the joke about
these these writings being a hoax ha ha
ha
because what he's saying is because the
letters the police were beginning to say
they're hoax and so what he's basically
saying is I say a good joke about these
things being a hoax ha ha ha well he's
not going following the line of police
thinking and of course then he signs the
Jack the Ripper and also looked for me
on a certain date like he's going to do
something else again
that's this all of these letters if you
begin to read the pattern of them this
is what they are like there are so many
of them with this ha ha ha ha ha and of
course one thing that's interesting
about that is his master Whistler who
was American and you didn't have a whole
lot of Brits do it going around going ha
ha it was really more of an American
thing back then but Whistler was
notorious for his ha ha it was said to
grate against the ear of England because
you could hear him if you were in this
room right now with this little monocle
held up he be going ha ha and that was
his ha ha and it drove people crazy
and so sicker think how many times a day
he heard that ha ha in the studio and he
had a real love hate relationship with
Whistler his master or something you can
read about in the book I won't go in a
lot of detail now but what the point I
wanted to make is I apologize for this
coal that won't go away
these are just two very minor samples of
the mockery the hatred you know what a
fool you are the police are double-faced
asses they're idiots that are in all
this and the two letters that
irrefutably I mean you have to say
they're from the same paper match can
you believe two different people did
that with 24 sheets of paper I always
wonder why people leave am I being
overly sensitive
one of them is promising to murder
somebody in another night or two and the
other which is quite fascinating it says
he's talking about many mumait NIA for
experiment home for experiments and he
says you can find the missing parts here
well this was dated October 4th 1888 two
days earlier they found a torso of a
woman buried in not buried but shoved
into a recess in the foundations of the
New Scotland Yard building that's a big
haha he asked me it was in the process
of being constructed and they found an
arm and a leg but they never found her
head that was the most important thing
and there's a lot in the newspapers
about finding the other body parts
because they could not identify so two
days after that he's talking about you
can find the missing parts here there's
a cartoon drawn on it in this comp this
was on his mother's stationery now if
you want to argue that that's a crank I
don't think so
but that's just a little bit and this is
that you know it's just amazing what
forensic science has done if they if we
if this Institute and other people can
do this with something this old and
we're not finished yet
think what they can do with crimes today
if we have the funding if we have the
interest we have the support and we look
at and we look at crimes and how their
works for what they really are which is
not Hollywood
you know it's pain and death in real
blood and people who work in slave away
long hours without getting paid a whole
lot and it are tremendously understaffed
and I'm going to open the floor to
questions in one second but I just ask
one thing of you please care because you
know what it can happen to anybody it's
not about other people it's about all of
us now who would like to ask a question
it is
yes sir really enjoyed it
you mentioned thank you tonight about
some new information that have come out
simulation book and in the book we
talked about diary or clippings book
believe detective my question is what
information or what are you going to do
in the future to keep us updated
well I'm electing another book next year
well what's going to happen that's a
very good question and it's pretty
simple although not well actually it
isn't such an unpleasant answer I will
update the paper back when the paperback
comes out next year I've already I've
already told the publisher first time
ever I don't know that this ever
happened before they sent me my disk
back because I'm gonna have to put it
back in my computer other thing that
went into typeset and I've already got
so many changes that have to be made
things added I need you know there's
other people things come up like this
brilliant psychologist and in what he
asked him I said will you look at these
Ripper letters and tell me are these
crank confessions or what's different
about them and I said I don't care what
your answer is I just want the truth
so whatever that is that's going to go
in the book the science is going to go
to the book the next 50 DNA
mitochondrial results from Bodie I going
to go in the book even if I don't like
them and that's you know so that for
sure will happen and then you know this
is a criminal investigation this is so
it has to be followed for as long as it
continues to speak and people find more
secret letters with incriminating
watermarks you know oh god I wish
something would turn up I'd love to get
you know his DNA profile we are kind of
you know we're snooping around still
seeing if we can find he had himself
cremated which i think was quite rude
and so you know and believe me I'd be
out in the night with a shovel if that
weren't true and so just a little piece
nobody will know just I don't know which
piece I took but it wouldn't be nice
anyway we we walk this will continue and
here's one of the best parts about it I
want to tell you this it's a it's not
only about the dead because we I know I
mentioned 1415 cases that you could
possibly link to the Ripper he did keep
killing he was a serial killer we will
never know how many nameless women
children who knows you know were
dismembered because he did get into
dismemberment and we're never missed
because these types of people weren't
missed they didn't do missing person
reports back then and even if you were
not a prostitute so but somebody said to
me why does it matter 114 years later
why does it matter about you know these
these ladies I mean the whole notion of
just especially when you spent so much
money on it isn't it a little silly well
think of this for a minute
let's take Elizabeth stride whose throat
was cut on the night early our mornings
of September 30th 1888 the throat was
cut so badly was all the way back to her
spine which means she of course bled out
through her major blood vessels
hemorrhage but she also since her
windpipe was severed may have begun may
also have been drowning in her own blood
it was not it was a terrible way to die
they didn't die instantly like it was
said in the police surgeon and inquest
reports back then nobody dies instantly
do they Marcella she say she's shaking
her head that no they don't and I would
live she were doing otherwise
so because you can't hear so Elizabeth
stride she's buried in the cemetery and
I did go visit the cemetery I went to
all the cemeteries all the graves that
are still there she's buried in this
East London Cemetery
actually a very lovely Cemetery this is
a real shock to me because I know of all
the
Ripper walks and you know what a big
thing it's actually an industry so I got
to this little information desk inside
this cottage it was raining
I don't know springtime summer and I
went in and I I said this can someone
tell me where Elizabeth strides grave is
and this guy was busy kind of blowing me
off and there's just kind of early guy
with a beard and he said all he says I
can tell you I know where she is and I
said will you take me to her and he said
sure will so we'd go out turns out he's
a gravedigger and I've never met a
gravedigger before and I was quite
what's really strange though is you know
you have these conversations and if I
put this in a novel you're not going to
believe this right this big burly guy
were walking through the rain he does
not believe in back hoes I had a long
lecture on back hoes the evils of back
hoes and you should dig all graves by
hand and so we're walking through
looking for Elizabeth and then I said
well um have you always been a
gravedigger you said no I used to sell
men's clothing okay I mean it made sense
to me if maybe it's somehow connected
with the funeral business you know those
suits that don't have a back on them but
I couldn't
well isn't isn't it true I've been to
funeral home conventions where they have
bubbles blowing everywhere and coffin
shaped like cars and let's get off that
subject
but is it he showed me her grave this
little brass plate in the ground and I
said you must get a lot of people
looking for her and he said nope I
thought that was so sad so this is what
I have to say about why this matters now
Elizabeth stride was dead when she was
put into that ignored clod of Earth in
England in early in the fall of 1888 she
is no more dead now than she was then so
was it ever too late for justice and why
does it matter it doesn't matter to her
she doesn't really know as far as we can
tell but we do if we again we know and
we must have justice for us it is for
those of us left behind or we are not a
decent society and I think that whenever
we have an opportunity in this you know
why would I I couldn't walk away from
this you have to unveil a killer to that
who has committed these kinds of crimes
so that matters the second reason this
matters is that in terms of forensic
disciplines whether its DNA
mitochondrial DNA whether it's image
enhancement whether it is fingerprint so
we're still working on those because
there's three of them on Ripper letters
whether it is a different way of
approaching disguised handwriting
whether it is the paper analysis which
is amazing every one of these
disciplines can be brought to more
attention because of this case and I'm
hoping that all people who have been
involved in it the professionals will
write papers about it will presented at
meetings and show what can be done in
the face of almost impossibility so it
is about the living it is not just about
the past now who else would like to ask
a question yes sir
and I'll try not to be so terse yes I
spent some time over in England quite a
bit of time actually and I got a chance
to deal with Scotland Yard and they're
pretty adept at what they do I was
wondering if why are you investigating
this if you found anything of whether
it's more of a botched investigation or
number of because he was a high cultural
figure now there was no cover-up except
by secret when he put makeup on and went
out did his bad things on the streets
because he know they had secret was
never a suspect back then and he this is
this guy was a genius I mean he really
was I mean if you when you read about
him I can't take that away from him he
was a very unusual artist in that he was
he was very creative but he was also
mathematical and signs you know good in
science I'm creative but you don't even
want to talk about my math but he never
was a suspect and no though I don't
think they would have covered up for him
I think the one person who might have
covered up for him would have been his
wife and I always will wonder how much
Ellen knew she was a tragic characters
his first wife who's married three times
but I've always wondered because he what
greater shame could be brought upon her
father's name than if he'd been the if
his son-in-law had been Jack the Ripper
and ironically one of Richard Cobden who
is this politician a tremendously humane
you can't read this book you can't read
about Richard Cobden who would have been
sick his father-in-law had he been alive
still you can't you can't help but love
him he was such a wonderful humanitarian
and one of his best friends was Robert
Peel who is the one who started the
Metropolitan Police Department that
eventually defeated what would have been
Richard Cobden son-in-law so it's kind
of a strange twist but no there was
there was no cover-up the police did the
best he could this was way beyond as I
say in the book was a hundred years
beyond their expertise to deal with a
criminal this magnitude who else yes sir
can you do that a little I liked the fan
part you're not pathetic critic he read
the book twice once as a fan I go on
[Applause]
that truck she fills up in your ear
you know I believe that that's who it
was when I read it as a fan the passion
and the emotion and you know they
consumed so much of a part of you you
know what's next for you I don't know
now what's next for me no I'm really
excited about what's next for me you
know with life when life takes you down
a road you never thought you'd go down
and you really think I'm going to die
because I don't know how I'm going to do
this and you need to understand I want
to tell you the honest truth about this
I hate that honest truth because it's
just the truth what we won't be
redundant here I don't tell you the
truth this was a miserable experience
for me it is the hardest thing I ever
have done I was depressed most of the
time I did it I mean really unhappy
because I could not be creative it was
like living in a world where there was
no color and living in a world where
there was nothing good everybody was
either poor wretched sick miserable
dying being murdered or else they were
this jerk you know the psychopath who
thought it was fun to go cut out
people's organs and do all these awful
things that he did and yet became one of
the most you know prominent painters in
England it was miserable and it cost me
a fortune I never
I really do compared to raising the
Titanic this little Patricia out in a
rowboat she drops the hook and oh my god
what does it catch on this big old
friggin ship down there it has one
little rusty eye hook sticking up and it
catches my hook and I say oh okay well
I'll throw a few bucks out there let's
get a little you know something bigger
to me and next thing I know six million
dollars later it's like ten feet below
you below the surface and you say do I
just drop it or do I go on well you know
what I had to do but I never ever
imagined so I mean who wants to spend
that kind of money there's a lot more
than I got paid to write it I'll tell
you and it's very unlikely that I'll
ever get it back plus I missed a whole
year of writing Scarpetta which and I'm
not going to complain about money but
I'm just saying you know it it's I just
was involved to go to the
in a panel at the economic summit in
Geneva and I think it's because they one
is for a joke you know I think that they
want me on a panel is a little levity to
lighten things up I mean why would
anybody want me to be on a panel at an
economic summit please tell me so but
how how is that going to change I I
cannot be anything but a different
person because I have I've been pretty
beaten up the Brits were really tough I
thought I did something good I said you
know this is justice and this is a
celebration of these great scientists I
didn't do this science they did and it's
I thought this is so wonderful I never
thought that people would hate you for
it so get over it
and say don't tough luck you know he
still did it so what but you know it was
really quite a rude awakening to to be
under fire the way it's worse over there
I mean I was there for Thanksgiving and
it's the first time I was ever really
truly moved by the holiday and I just
wish and I think you know said John
Smith you go boy you go boy so but I
think Scarpetta I think number one I'm
not sure I could ever write a funny book
about crime again mail and my satirical
things maybe that will change not that I
think that I ever was critical I mean
that I was irreverent about crime and
things like hornet's nest and in
Southern Cross and I love dogs
but I don't I don't have it in me
anymore for that kind of satire I don't
I've been too wounded by this it's too
heavy it's just too heavy I had to live
these victims are real to me and and I
think that was the Scarpetta book that
I'm about to start it will have layers
and textures and I think things you've
never seen before
because I am a different person because
I had to work a real case and I have a
whole different understanding of police
prosecutors victims all of it and ni and
I am thankful for that because it makes
me feel that it is sensitive
as I thought I was
think you know this is a whole new level
for me and I hope that I have more to
offer you as a result who else
yes out of all the books that you've
brought to us is there any time that you
were doing an investigation that you are
actually scared that I would do an
investigation where I was scared yeah
when you were doing some of your
investigation work or research work on
gathering your information to write your
book is there anything you've ever seen
or done that scared you or about the act
that was committed that scared you yeah
not the dead people though they're
really quite nice I have never had a
cross word with a single one of them no
I tell you what scared me the most that
I ever did is when I decided when I was
working on cause of death and Scarpetta
has to go do this dive into the
Elizabeth River and you can't and this
murky cold and Marcella wouldn't do it
she said she's pretty she's a chief
medical examiner of Virginia and I said
you know you've never done this research
so what it would be like to scuba dive
and get this body out and she would not
cooperate with me so I had to go learn
how to scuba dive and get my you know
certified and I will tell you first time
I went down in the pool you know with a
regulator on I came out and threw up
I've never thrown up at an autopsy but
every cell in my body said are you
stupid
you don't inhale underwater and I've
that I really had a phobia I had a
phobia of the diving well that was bad
enough so I get certified and why do you
pick the San Francisco Bay that's stupid
to talk about a rotten place with kelp
lashing out at you everywhere you go
rocks drunk fishermen with spears that's
frightening
so so then I go we get permission from
the Navy to go to the inactive shipyard
you know where the scene is and cause of
death and not you it's the worst part of
it was when I got my dive gear guess
what the only thing they had left were
pink fins
a pink mask in pink find--and I'm trying
to have credibility I mean Danielle
Steel has more credibility than me
so I don't put those pictures on my
website so here I am do you think the
Navy takes me seriously they're all
standing around you know on a Saturday
morning I'm there my little pink fins
and my little pink mask and I'm getting
ready to jump in to find a dead body
that isn't there and one of the guys he
had his fly down the other was drunk
god bless america I hope they're doing
better now don't send the Navy they go
to Iraq please but and this is true
story it really is so I finally jump in
and then have the very unhappy
realization that you can't see anything
because of the rust and everything I
described in that part of the Scarpetta
book including her tank being knocked
off by cable that's really it's a lovely
experience I want you to someday swim in
frigid water in pink fins hit a cable
and have it and fill your tank sliding
down your back so you got this where
your head going back like this I thought
I was really going to die and that that
was the so anyway I did manage to get
out of that one but that was the worst
thing I've ever had to do I will not do
that again if she wants to scuba dive
that baby is on her own it's not that's
not for me and I'm not jumping out of an
airplane either
who else yes
hi I'm with the Bodhi Technology Group
and I just want to say it's been an
honor to work with you on the jacket
Ripper case
but I have to ask a case worker scarf
had a question I've been dying to ask
you this question how could you kill
Benton 20 minutes I have a question for
you but did you guys by chance do
mitochondrial DNA on his bones and it's
a good well how do you know it's him I
[Applause]
think that's in the next book right
si se nothing but you know never make
assumptions when science has not entered
the picture yet
[Applause]
my mother will be so pleased to hear
that my mom came with me to this event
last year and when we went home I gave
her post-mortem to read and she is a
speed reader I just blasted right
through it and a month ago she called me
at work to say she was ready for her
next book and I had to tell her that was
all there was because she had worked her
way through the same thing my age I know
for me I hate that do anyway I was
wondering you mentioned a couple of
times that we keep hearing there are
five victims there were five victims how
far do you think this goes how many do
you think there really were probably
Bill Hagemeyer can answer that better me
bill you need to write a book about this
I think it's hard to say you know
there's there's a serial killer just
recently I mean not so long ago who was
remember he was going to train stops and
getting off and killing people they
think he killed as many as 80 people
it's hard to say but I do in my book I
tribute a 1907 homicide to Walter
Sickert which would have made him 47 he
started I think at age 28 as best we can
tell but you know he lived to be 81 my
guess is he very well could have gone
into his 50s because he had a number of
years where he was a he was a bachelor
again and then he got married a third
time when he was 66 and you probably
read in the paper not just the other day
about these a sex slave murders the guy
was 62 or something but he he would have
kept going
I suppose until the impulse or his
physical health or whatever would have
waned but I you know not necessarily at
the frenzied pace he was doing in 1888
and 1889 and you'll see there are cases
in 1889 one in particular is identical
to the others in the police surgeon who
did the autopsy said this is the work of
the same thing and it was just ignored
you know so it's I hate to think but I
guarantee you it was a lot yes ma'am
that's the right height my question
deals with you said it was 1942 you
think it's the time of death for this
individual
yeah January 22nd 1942 and that's not
very far behind here so is there DNA
from family or associate if they're even
willing to talk about well this is good
Russia and if so what kind of DNA
structure well I'm ready to dig them all
up if I can find them but the family as
far as we know Walter Sickert never had
any children and interestingly enough as
far as we know none of his family he had
five four brothers a sister there's six
six and none of them had children as far
as we know and that kind of strange is
like it must be a DNA thing in there
somewhere where maybe the double helix
got time and not I don't know but he as
far as we know he never had children and
when you you read this in the book he
was born with a deformity of as the
Victorians called it as pretty part good
thing to tell your children when you
don't want to get too explicit right so
he had three major surgeries on that by
the time he was five and in 1860s I
would call that actual medical violence
with what he must have gone through and
I again you can read that stuff but
there's a its most highly likely he was
sexually dysfunctional and which might
explain why he never had any children
that we are aware of so that would leave
there that would leave the mitochondrial
process if he hadn't been cremated you
know you could possibly gotten nuclear
DNA from him and maybe if you had
somebody else related to them like a
brother or whatever I don't know you're
getting me into I start getting into the
brambles about all this and I can sense
it and I'm going to run back to the
grass but the fact is he was cremated we
do have and we'll see for sure of this
what appears to be a mitochondrial
sequence from male that you know stamps
and so forth you could get it through
the mother's bloodline
now we fear his sister may have been
cremated as well I don't
what this was with these people but that
I think they were truly not religious
people at all and this was a little
unusual the way they all decided to
cremate themselves I guess we're looking
yes so your best hope would be his
mother for a mitochondrial sequence but
and you know what we'll see if we're
looking but I don't know I don't want to
get into that part thank you about
whether people enjoy oh yeah come dig
her up what let's just do everything
else over here why not so I don't I
don't know where that's going to go but
I think what's important is that we
already can link these letters to him
and then it's and then it's really up to
people as you said it would
Scotland Yard said they would put this
before the Queen's prosecutor he would
be indicted based on these letters I
think then it's up to a jury and a good
prosecutor to convince make a good case
for a seeming seemingly normal man who's
never done this in any other case we
know of and whose letters you know are
the type I described that would he do
this along with all the other
circumstantial evidence in his life that
you'll read about and not have committed
the crimes
so what last question look how shy
people go not her go ahead oh we enacted
two more because you're there and I'm
going to let you do it too so go ahead
maybe a bit of an unfair question oh
then I get it going has been a couple of
national cases of special interest I
think to almost everyone in this room
about the incompetence of for instance
the Boulder Colorado forensic unit and
the Los Angeles Department with the OJ
Simpson I'm just wondering I'm just
going to open up I don't really have a
question but I know that there is a an
international team of forensic
scientists in this room and I'm
wondering what your view is about what a
team like this could bring to closure or
understanding of those two cases I what
I would say about cases like that is
sure there are people out there that
don't know what they're doing don't care
what they're doing are incompetent but
for the most part what you're going to
find is that there is such a dearth of
training I mean you send police officers
to a crime scene and they've got to know
what's evidence and I'll give you a good
example you take the Chandra Levy case
now I didn't see the remains that were
left in the woods but take a case like
that where you have basically a very
badly decomposed or skeletonized body
one of the things that happens with
these bodies is the outs the skin the
upper layer of your skin on your hand
they end up with anthropologists
basically call it a glove because it's
you have skin slippage when you
decompose nice subject don't eat and
this comes off and it looks sort of like
a dead leaf and if a police officer
hasn't been trained at a death
investigation school like we have here
at the Institute and they're beginning
to have some in other places he might
completely walk past that well guess
what that is that's that person's
fingerprints because you can get that
and rehydrate it and you can they
literally will put it on over a surgical
glove and print it you can put those
prints in a database or them it might be
the only means of identifying this
person if you can't get a pre-mortem DNA
sample for example but maybe their
fingerprint somewhere but I mean that's
a really weird piece of evidence is
something you have to be an expert to
find so I think in in these cases like
even the JonBenet Ramsey case if you do
not have police and you do not have
properly trained scientists your
evidence your case is only as good as
your evidence and that is why we are all
here tonight is to give money to make
this better because I don't think it's
done out of malice I think it's done out
of it's just done because it's all
they've got and then you'll be the last
one tonight I know it's a lot of
pressure for me to answer it so do you
want to come up to the microphone real
quick or can you leave in a project
do you think that favors early surgeries
as a boy are what led him to do prom I
think these early surgeries had to have
had an impact on him
and I think when you read about them you
you have to have a tremendous amount of
pity for this little boy I mean we don't
even know the three operations indicated
that his deformity was severe enough or
there were complications enough that one
surgery wasn't enough and what we don't
know that and if all of them or perhaps
even any of them if he had anesthesia
and and what they did back then is you
you'd have a nurse hold the boy down
legs apart
pretty much hogtied and maybe he got
chloroform which would and then they
used leeches this is what they believed
back then is if you had inflammation
which you're going to have god help you
after I mean I don't want to get into
detail makes us all in pain but if you
had think of this little kid in bed he's
German he was born in Munich he's now in
a London hospital he's not even hearing
his mother tongue being spoken there's
no if there's no Children's Ward it's
mostly poor people in their support
person's Hospital there's no night nurse
god knows what he suffered and then the
nurse comes in maybe he's got some Lynne
from inflammation from the surgery
well that was believed to be due to an
excess of blood so what do you do you
bring in the pan of leeches now imagine
that so and I will also add that it was
there was a belief back in the Victorian
era that if a woman was immoral such as
a prostitute then she had a genetic
defect that was passed through the
bloodline
well secrets mother was illegitimate and
her mother was a dancehall immoral woman
basically a prostitute in secret was the
firstborn of that illegitimate mother
and he was born with a physical
deformity which basically took away his
manhood and uknow
is reading tea leaves a little bit but
you could speculate that there might
have been good reason for him to hate
prostitute
and spend all his time going to dance
halls and music halls listen thank you
you've been a great audience I'll be
happy to sign your books I love all of
you Patricia Cornwell is author of the
last precinct and Isle of Dogs her
latest portrait of a killer is published
by Putnam visit penguin Putnam com for
more information